now to the winner this young woman
really wants to change things for the
better but her nominators say she's also
really good fun caring considerate and
thoughtful her colleagues value her
tremendously she lives her liberal
Democrat values in every way possible
unafraid determined demanding better for
women and better from government and
systems her outstanding commitment and
dedication has meant that in a very
short space of time she and the team
have a change achieved a major change in
the law now she may not be visible to
you but her nominators say she went well
above and beyond her duty in her role
she tackled Tory MPs and senior civil
servants who were against the upskirting
bill and forced them to listen she spent
many hours working on the bill alongside
her other duties working with
researchers writers Clark's the House of
Commons and influencing MPs from all the
other parties journalists and civil
servants now despite the fact she didn't
front the work her boss and one of her
greatest cheerleaders Vera hop House MP
says she is quite extraordinary and
what's more she's just 21 years old and
in her first job at Westminster so it
gives me great pleasure to give the
Patsy Colton award to Jess Clayton
- elation
[Applause]
hang on okay thank you thank you very
much now we finally come to the
President's Award and this award is to
recognize members who have over many
years demonstrated excellent service to
the party well above and beyond the call
of duty and this year we have four
winners because it was just impossible
to decide between each and every one of
them who are outstanding and each
thoroughly deserved to win I'm going to
ask them all to come up together at the
end first is an individual who joined
the party 60 years ago and I'm reliably
informed that during those 60 years not
a week has gone by went without him
doing something for the party canvassing
in every general election from 1959 to
2017 and with no sign of stopping
anytime soon
his indomitable services to the party
continue still with his being elected to
his local parish council this year aged
85 for the very first time of asking
Martin curl is the first of our winners
next is a man who has done just about
every volunteer job in the party that
you can do chair of his local party
member of the Federal Executive member
of federal conference committee chair of
his regional candidates committee and
then chair of his region he
reinvigorated a flagging parliamentary
candidates Association nearly 20 years
ago which grew in strength and provided
vital support to many of us candidates
over those years one fun fact that you
may not know about jock Galica for it is
he is that he was the program chief and
editor for the archers on BBC radio
perhaps that's why Mark Hebden stood for
the SDP jocks contribution to the party
over many decades is inspirational he's
a credit to the West Midlands and they
are lucky to have him and and his talent
in their ranks thank you
I hope that you won't our next winner
won't mind me saying that he looked
really relieved when he turned up for
conference this week for the first time
in many years long as I can remember in
fact he's so relieved he's actually gone
back to work today so can't be with us
he was chair of your federal conference
committee for over eight years before
standing down earlier this year he saw
us through with confidence all that was
new to our party when we went into power
and coalition including increased
security and everything else that went
with it which I'm sure you will remember
and he did it with such a good humor and
a dedication to ensuring that you
members got the debate on the topics
that were important to you so I hope
that this award shows our gratitude for
all the hard work that Andrew Wiseman
has put in
the last winner is an unstoppable force
of liberalism re-elected to Camden
Council this year for the ninth time and
in her 33rd year as a councillor she was
first elected back in 1986 topping the
poll in her ward which she do lead it
again this May during her time on the
council this remarkable woman has served
as group leader building the group up
from two members in one Ward to 20
councillors and forming the
administration now as well as this in
2014 a particularly difficult election
in Camden she held on winning the only
Lib Dem seat in the borough continuing
the fight for liberal ISM as she has
done all these years with two Lib Dems
winning alongside her this May she is
now group leader again and we look
forward to seeing where she takes them
next it is of course the wonderful flick
ray wood all three of you please come up
onto the stage
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're European aren't there in there you
know and there we go thank you very much
thank you to all our Award winners so
here we are conference at the end of
conference after a few short days and I
really want to say thank you to all
those who make conference not just
possible but a stunning success so from
the Lib Dems here is a huge thank you to
all the staff here at the Brighton
Center who've hosted our conference and
exhibition particularly to Don Hurley
and his team of a new event manager and
not forgetting the brilliant staff at
the Hilton led by Sarah cross and we
thank Brighton for welcoming us all with
open arms
we are supported we are supported by
fantastic suppliers who care about the
success of conference just as much as we
do Chris dan and his crew at quark they
run the show they make this fantastic
stage set and always go above and beyond
the call of duty and the same goes for
the fantastic Aztec team led by Cameron
mccurdy who supply all our audio-visual
throughout conference they enable our
training events to be heard and the
material to be seen and as always please
give a special thanks to our British
sign language interpreters the fabulous
Clair Edwards Hodge attractive and Jayne
Barnett
they provide such an invaluable service
I want to add something special in here
you will remember the rally on Friday
night and I want to especially thank
Claire for her beautiful rendition of
the choirs songs artistic and rhythmic
thank you and after I shouted out a
certain phrase all three of them have
had to sign bollocks
do brexit a lot not just me all of you
so now you know what bollocks to brexit
looks like
we are supported throughout by SP a
complete event services who ensure we
run a safe and secure conference and who
as always have shown great humor and
professionalism all week thanks to Jerry
and his team and a big THANK YOU also to
our conference sponsors exhibitors
advertisers and fringe organizers who
helped to create an interesting debate
outside of the main conference
auditorium a big THANK YOU to to federal
conference committee and federal policy
committee and to our utterly amazing
stewards team see them in their yellow
shirts all around us thank you
thank you to all the parliamentary staff
and the whips offices who work so hard
behind the scenes and also our HQ teams
the policy office campaigns diversity in
candidates office press office the
membership team the international office
the fundraising team and of course last
but most important the conference office
our head of conference Mike Smith who
leads a team made up of Jack Everett
diver Kistler and Emma price now in fact
this is Mike divers and Jack's last
conference good luck to them in their
future and many many thanks to them all
and finally I want to say two more thank
yous first to you the members once again
you have shown to the outside world the
face of a United Party but one that is
unafraid to have a strong debate with
each other both in the hall but also
around the fringes of conference you do
listen to each other and argue fiercely
but at the end of each day we come back
together as a family
because we share common values thank you
and finally I want to thank my leader
Vince Cable Vince your first year as
leader has just whizzed by and during
that year we have one more by-elections
he stayed 75 elect see more seats in the
local elections and our poll rating is
moving up steadily indeed this morning
you have said we were at 11% the media
are turning to you as the voice of
economic experience and someone who is
unafraid to say that we should have a
people's vote and that Liberal Democrats
will fight for the UK's place in the EU
conference is all but over
we're almost ready for that final act
but just before we hear from Vince
please welcome Lord Mike German a bit of
American music which I wanted it to play
we'll see I hope you recognize the music
[Applause]
better we
to need better choices that's why the
leader of the Liberal Democrats has
proposed an ambitious plan to change the
face of UK politics by seizing a
once-in-a-generation opportunity to
build a party into a movement step one
open up the party by creating a free
open and inclusive movement
step two let the people decide from a
broad range of candidates who the leader
of their movement should be step 3
empower this movement by giving everyone
a say over campaigning priorities step 4
make it easier for new members to stand
for public office and get involved in
community campaigns these proposals are
just the beginning as we begin our
consultation on how to build the most
open and modern movement in the UK
history you can have your say by
visiting our consultation portal at Lib
Dems org UK forward slash consultation
take a minute to share your ideas
complete a survey and search for public
consultations online or near you last
spring we passed a resolution to create
a political and social movement which
encourages people to take and use power
in their own lives and communities at
every level of society this is the time
for us to begin that movement together
it's time to demand better I want a
better future for my two sons
and I'm genuinely worried about the way
in which our country is going you know
and in my area I see often people who
are struggling struggling despite the
best efforts that struggling to achieve
a better life the government are
absolutely focused on delivering some
kind of brexit and actually they're not
talking at all about the real issues
that people have on a day to day basis
we've gotta focus on the things that
they people angry and getting richer
society better balance it isn't alone
now a lot of people work really hard
they're trying the best for their
families and they're just not getting
anything back I think as an MP you
really can make a difference if you're
listening to people and hearing their
concerns and you can help their voice
get louder I believe in working together
to solve problems and that actually if
you put your faith in an individual and
that actually they've got the answers
for their own life the job of government
as far as our liberal is concerned is to
take power to give it back to give
people the opportunity to make the base
for themselves people who already have
lots of money and assets wealth seem to
be able to make the system work for them
we're is in enormous Li the fact that
the big multinational corporates somehow
managed to avoid their responsibilities
they don't pay the tax I think that they
should be and they pay the staff but all
the proper living wage I think that
really irritates people and we just got
into mom better we've got to make sure
the
the system delivers for people it's the
government to make sure that we have a
proper system of taxation there's an MP
my job is to demand better for my
constituent and try and fix the system
from within people respond to that they
want things to improve and for so long
now they've not really been seeing the
improvement so you know I think it's
right that we really do demand better
from government things should be better
you've got a right to have better
services and as Liberal Democrats we
demand better services the time for
waiting is over only the Liberal
Democrats have the ideas the experience
the commitment to transform the fortunes
of our country an exit from brexit a
grown-up approach to the economy and
bold ideas to strengthen our society
through the 21st century I'm ready to
take our message out to the country and
I ask you to join me on the journey as
we together take the Liberal Democrats
back to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you conference we meet here at an
absolutely crucial moment because in the
next few months the future of our
country will be decided for decades to
come and history will record that
Liberal Democrats have been on the right
side of the brexit argument we were
right to oppose brexit in the first
place we were right to predict a bad
deal and we have been right to campaign
for a people's vote
[Applause]
[Applause]
but this party knows better than any
other that there are no prizes for being
right you know we have to win and the
good news is that we are winning the
argument brexit has left millions of
people feeling frustrated and powerless
and unrepresented
so as we campaign for a different future
we're inviting those people into our
movement it's not only those who voted
remain that a wills more and more people
are thinking again there is now a
growing realization that brexit will be
costly and painful it will be very
costly and very painful if we crash out
without a deal the brexit day may be the
29th of March but he sees only maybe
brexit is not inevitable it can and it
must be stopped
[Applause]
[Applause]
over the summer I spoke to rallies and
meetings across Britain from Bristol to
Newcastle to Cambridge and I saw that
there are huge numbers of people who
simply do not accept that we should
drift into a messy costly divorce who
don't accept that the country cannot
change its mind or that a narrow
majority decision for one generation
should light the chances of the next
there are millions of people out there
who haven't given up the fight and nor
will we
[Applause]
now I put the conservative brexit ears
into categories there are the true
believers the chances and the conscripts
and let me say a bit about each for the
true believers the the fundamentalists
the costs of brexit have always been
irrelevant years of economic pain
justified by the exotics present of
leaving the European Union economic pain
felt of course not by them but by those
at least able to afford it and the
latest piece of nastiness from Jacob
Riis MOG calling into question the right
of Europeans to stay in Britain and of
Britain's to stay in Europe creating
unnecessary worry and insecurity for
millions now I the public
I don't think mind what these people
dream about behind closed doors so long
as their dreams don't become nightmares
for the rest of us I mean it you know it
really beggars belief that the army and
the police are now being asked to
prepare for riots in the chaotic
aftermath of a botched brexit and
billions billions of taxpayers money is
being spent preparing for disaster do
you remember what we were promised it
was all going to be so easy painless
quickie Las Vegas style divorce and that
brings me to the chances and sabores the
Chancellor in chief
he and Michael Gove embrace wrecks it
after tossing a coin or making a cold
calculation about the quickest route to
the top of the Conservative Party and as
Boris discovered in the last Tory
leadership election Michael Gove is the
ideal man for a penalty shootout right
to the last moment you never know which
way will go for his part Boris Johnson
is a real danger to Britain it
[Applause]
he doesn't just resemble Trump you know
large Louden blonde he behaves more like
him every day their cynical disregard
for the truth the treatment of women and
their inflammatory divisive language
make Boris and Donald the terrible twins
of the rabid right
[Applause]
now the chances answer to the prospects
of pain is to ignore it or lie about it
or say it's all the fault of Europe but
the true believers and the chances will
save their greatest contempt for their
colleagues the conscripts among them the
Prime Minister the Chancellor the
Foreign Secretary the business secretary
these are people who have signed up to
brexit out of a misplaced sense of duty
they all see the benefits of staying in
the single market in the customs union
but they feel they must pretend
otherwise the conscripts are resigned to
a bad outcome
so rather than fight they've elevated
damaged limitation to a high principle
they fantasize over something called
frictionless convergence no wonder the
public doesn't understand what brexit is
supposed to mean I would go so far as to
say that some of us are starting to feel
sorry for the Prime Minister it seems
that even the European leaders are moved
to pity and it's obvious why she's
dutifully delivering a policy she
doesn't really believe in failing in
negotiations losing public support and
it's all to appease a dwindling group of
angry people in her own party that will
denounce her her as a traitor
whatever she comes up with but when we
feel sorry for the country's Prime
Minister something seriously wrong our
sympathy can only extend so far when she
puts the interests of the country second
to the whims of extremists in her party
[Applause]
deep down I believe the Prime Minister
knows that brexit is a bad idea it's a
bad idea whose time has gone and even
now Teresa may could shock us all by
displaying true leadership she could
admit that the brexit project has gone
badly wrong by conceding that the deal
any deal or no deal that she will bring
back from Brussels is not going to be
better for Britain than remaining in the
European Union instead of kowtow ting to
her enemies in the Conservative Party
she could lead her party and the country
by opening her mind to her people's vote
on the final deal
[Applause]
it's far far easier for Jeremy Corbyn to
be brave on brexit and this is his big
chance he used to be the campaigning
backbencher who joined us in opposing
the Iraq war and defending civil
liberties in his new role he's kept his
hands clean and His image polished by
hiring hard left boot boys and girls to
do his dirty work they do the bullying
and the intimidation and he claims not
to know he indulges anti-semitic bigots
and pleads ignorance but the nastiness
should not be allowed to obscure his
abstention from the biggest issue of the
day because next week hundreds thousands
of labour members and MPs will demand
that he changes course and backs a
public vote on the final deal and I
would say that if Jeremy Corbyn will not
say I will support a people's vote and I
will fight brexit labor members should
wave in goodbye
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the reason is that he's currently
letting down the many people in Labour's
heartland who now see brexit for what it
is it's a Tory project pursued futur
Ian's of which working people will be
the main victims but when we secure a
people's vote we then face a huge
challenge which is winning it I think we
have to recognize that brexit still
appeals to many hearts if not to many
minds the brick sic campaign stoked the
worst prejudices about race and
immigration do you remember those
loathsome advertisements featuring cues
of dark-skinned people and the
mendacious claim that we need to leave
the European Union to stop 80 million
Turks coming to live here this dread
dread --fill stuff but that was the
leave campaign not leave voters so we
must sell better the benefits that
immigration has brought to this country
do the workers who pay taxes to support
the welfare state and an aging
population and who are crucial to
everything from the NHS where there are
currently a hundred thousand vacancies
even today so the high-tech industries
but if we want to be heard we also have
to listen and we have to recognize that
although overall immigration has not
depressed wages there is a strong public
perception that it has done so in
particular places and particular
occupations or exacerbated pressures on
housing and services so we need to
invest in those parts of the country
which feel left behind and sure that
public funding keeps track of population
growth so public services can keep up
with demand
and I don't accept the idea that it is
some form of racism to want immigration
to be managed like other parts of the
economy I mean I should say I mean I
I've had personal experience of racism I
embarked on a mixed marriage in this
country when racism was rife and my wife
and children were being denounced as
people whose very presence here would
lead to rivers firming with blood and I
was thrown out of the parental home so I
will myself never waver in my commitment
to call out and stand up to racism in
all its forms but
but we we must understand that to
dismiss all brexit voters as racists is
simply wrong and completely
counterproductive
and as we persuade people of a future
within the European Union
we need to persuade them that the
European Union is changing
I want Liberal Democrats to be in the
vanguard of a europe-wide movement for
reform
opinion polling shows that disillusioned
with the European project is not unique
to Britain across Europe one in three
members of the public express
anti-european sentiment and rather than
let that grow we've got to take on those
who got Britain and the European Union
into the brexit mess and we can't do
that by just going on about the virtues
of the status quo macaw and neckl are
recognizing this in their countries too
they're in a very different place from
the position taken by the French and
German governments in 2016 whilst free
movement is an absolutely fundamental
principle of the European single market
the European Union may yet conclude that
protecting free movement as we must
means reforming free movement so justice
staying in the European Union is
essential to the future of the UK it is
crucial to the future of the European
Union to have a British liberal voice at
the table to argue
[Applause]
to argue as Edie Davey did on Sunday for
a liberal approach to manage migration
and to the refugee crisis for compassion
for the right to a better life and for
respecting family ties now more broadly
Europe needs a positive message of hope
for those who look back to the past
because for them it seemed genuinely
better and for those of experienced for
example a decade of depressed living
standards since the financial crisis
through no fault of their own the
industrialization globalization
competition liberalisation automation
all those shuns that were supposed to
represent progress have so often men to
move from skilled and respected jobs to
crap jobs from certainty to insecurity
now for them we need a positive message
and a positive argument for a reformed
Europe cooperating more not less on
research on harnessing new technologies
and setting world leading standards it
has to be a Europe which in standups of
the threats from Trump's America and an
increasingly aggressive Russia in short
a better Europe a Europe fit for the
21st century a Europe focused on its
citizens and with the UK at its heart
[Applause]
now a deep sense of nostalgia has driven
British politics in the last three years
but I want you now to imagine a future
where the brexit story has reached its
conclusion we've secured people's vote
and won we're back at the negotiating
table we're no longer seeking to leave
Europe but once again leading the debate
now try to imagine what a liberal social
democratic reforming government could
then bring to Britain our overriding
purpose would be to restore a sense of
fairness and opportunity to a country
where both have been lost now I've
always been a believer in a liberal
approach to the economy but we're
currently getting all the disadvantages
of a market economy and few of the
benefits it's an economy unhealthily
built on debt over indebted households
over indebted companies over indebted
government inadequate investment
stagnant wages grotesque rewards for
undeserving fat cats for short-term
performance and often outright failure
yeah it doesn't have to be like this a
better approach to business isn't an
idealistic fantasy now when I left
Parliament for a brief exile I became
and I remain the chair of one of the
country's largest social enterprises
perhaps for the benefit of the
journalists it's it's unpaid but HR ECT
is a highly successful transport company
which combines commercial discipline and
social purpose now many companies can
and do operates in this way
but it must be the norm and not the
exception we believe that there should
be ample opportunities for business to
invest and innovate to make money I know
and create jobs but we also believe in
active government we're not afraid to
intervene when the market fails as a
minister I was proud to launch with the
help of my Lib Dem colleagues the
financial tech sector through the
British business bank and the Green
Investment Bank and the catapult Network
which has created a launch pad for many
technological advances as part of a long
term industrial strategy and that's our
model for the future in the face of
relentlessly advancing new technologies
it's easy for people to feel powerless
and threatened so we have to understand
and regulate some of the new
technologies coming down the track so
that's why Jos Winston and I are setting
up a commission to look at how to turn
emerging technologies from a threat into
an opportunity and if we embrace these
technologies try to imagine some of the
potential know the potential for
robotics in care homes for machine
learning which can detect the first
signs of a malignant tumor or detect
fraud for blockchain which can enable
massive secure clinical trials and
quantum computing which can out compute
computers now Britain can and should be
a leader in these fields investing
massively in our science and technology
base and also imagine how a government
that wasn't distracted by the cost and
the trouble of brexit
could use its strengths and its
borrowing power to invest in the
environmentally sustainable
infrastructure that Britain so
desperately needs
[Applause]
we travel from or try to travel from
Workington to hull or swansea to Wrexham
or Dover to Penzance let alone smaller
places on the way now these are truly
epic journeys which show how pulley
connected modern Britain remains even
the much hype northern powerhouse has
dwindled to little more than an unheeded
cry for help now we can start to put
this right by breaking with the
economically foolish convention of
public sector accounting which treats
borrowing for productive investment in
the same way as day-to-day spending
the demands of climate change alone
require that bonus if you take the title
the ghoul in South Wales the Tory
government has killed it and we would
resurrect it
[Applause]
and imagine putting the country to work
building the green Britain of tomorrow
with hundreds of miles of new railways
and broadband cabling that is the future
a liberal social democratic reforming
government could bring wood also wants a
resurrect a sense of fair play in the
way that government raises money the tax
proposals you endorsed this week would
be a start we need to reverse the trend
of fewer and fewer people hoarding the
nation's wealth
[Applause]
those are modest incomes should pay less
tax and indeed Liberal Democrats in
government delivered lower taxes for the
low paid but the wealthiest should pay
more now our reforms which you passed
this morning could raise substantial
sums now we would not splash the money
on short-term spending it would be
invested in a sovereign wealth fund
saving for the future and that fund
would be further boosted by the eventual
sale of RBS shares the public need
reassurance that their taxis are put to
good use and that's why we argue for a
penny in the pound on income tax
earmarked for the NHS and Social Care as
a stepping stone to a tax specifically
set aside for the NHS
[Applause]
and and we would concentrate its funding
on the mental health crisis
building on Norman's lambs work in
government and there are other services
crying out for money
schools are seriously underfunded the
police have been cut back to dangerous
levels and crime is rising as a
consequence and local government has
been outrageously undermined now
addressing these and other interventions
requires additional tax and when the
next election comes our manifesto will
spell out progressive tax reforms and
also an honest approach to tax the
principle is clear that every citizen
and company should pay their fair share
and get something back for what they put
in because nothing gets up the noses of
honest taxpayers more than a government
squeezing every penny it can out of
small firms while rolling out the red
carpet for world-class tax dodgers like
Amazon Facebook and Google
[Applause]
[Applause]
and to that end we want a renewed
offensive against individual and
corporate tax don't you in addition we
will scrapped the outdated business
rates which are destroying our high
streets and reform company taxation for
the digital age now contrast all of that
with today's Labour Party from the
coterie of people around Jeremy Corbyn
who until very recently were on the
stalinist wing of the microscopic
British Communist Party and from
economic policies which are based on a
nostalgic view of the commanding heights
of the economy which are more relevant
to the steam age than to the digital age
and in addition unlike them we do not
believe in magic money trees and pots of
gold at the end of the rainbow
what we do believe in is in the power of
education and leather Marana set out the
blueprint for a Britain which will
prepare young people with both the
academic and vocational education they
need to get on in life putting the
education profession back in charge
cutting testing and valuing teeth
reimagining inspection so that schools
are judged not on how many boxes they've
text that how many children's lives
they've changed and supporting schools
who teach the most disadvantaged
children the pupil premium was a liberal
Democrat invention and success and it
must be increased so that more money is
targeted towards helping children from
the poorest backgrounds
[Applause]
by contrast the present government's
financial squeeze on skills is leading
teachers and assistants to be made
redundant and special needs to be
neglected and all the while scarce
resources are diverted to the Tory
Party's ideological hobbyhorse of
grammar schools selective admissions are
creeping back a generation after the
eleven plus was consigned to the history
books we should be clear selection is a
byword for division it sets school
against School pupil against pupil and
it drives down standards overall it is
totally the wrong priority
[Applause]
beyond school we have to ensure a better
future for all young people those were
they stars at a level usually leave
their hometowns and don't come back but
those who struggle to get a few GCSEs
stay behind the bigger cities and towns
have their own university the rest make
do with the local tech but it's actually
the local Tech which should be at the
forefront of the drive to equip the
country for wrenching technological
change and global competition
[Applause]
as the fourth Industrial Revolution
takes hold only the Liberal Democrats
recognize that education is for all and
for life and not just for the very
clever the very rich or the very
fortunate
[Applause]
government has a key role in making all
this happens so I will bring to the
spring conference detailed proposals for
the individual learning account to
finance training and Retraining through
life and contrast that approach with the
Tories version of the apprenticeship
levy which is actively discouraging
training and to the Tory acts which he's
been taking to funds for lifelong
learning the broad Democrats would offer
young people the prospect of a decent
education from nursery on the lifelong
learning required for the emerging job
market and one final piece of the puzzle
the prospect of a decent home because
nothing illustrates the government's
paralysis of will more than the abject
failure to get to grips with the
inadequate supply of housing
[Applause]
sorry governments under Churchill and
Macmillan built 300 thousand houses a
year and now they struggle to deliver
half of that for a much bigger
population new social house building has
almost stopped owner occupation is
becoming a distant dream if you remember
the Conservatives used to be the party
of the homeowner even they've now become
the party of the absentee landlord and
the insecure tenant
[Applause]
sleeping on the streets has become
appallingly commonplace see if you've
seen it here in Brighton and it cannot
be justified in a civilized society
[Applause]
and meanwhile the government pursues a
failed model under which developers only
build and landowners only sell when they
can confidently expect rising prices big
housing developers like Berkeley homes
and Barrett's and persimmons now these
are mainly you know land speculation
machines with a sideline in house
building so so what we insist on is that
there must be an ambitious program of
council house building by councils
building freed from central government
control
[Applause]
an end to the enforced sale of social
housing
and we desperately need a program of
low-cost homes for rent leading to
purchase for the first-time buyers and
key workers and it can be done you know
successful long-standing Liberal
Democrat councils like eastleigh have
gone on and done it
there's no ideological dogma it's just
hard work and commitment and that is
what people have come to expect from
their Lib Dem councils and councillors
now we've begun to imagine a better
Britain after the brexit nightmare but
the challenge remains how to give people
a way to engage in politics which offers
genuine hope that things can get better
and that's why last week I put forward
proposals to remake and open up our own
party to turn the Liberal Democrats into
a gray movement our party is still very
pale and very male and we've got to
change that and keep growing welcoming
more and more people in extending our
trust to supporters by giving them a say
in our leadership opening up the field
of leadership candidates and making it
easier for people to get involved in
community politics and stand for
political office reaching out we start
from 100,000 members another 200,000
supporters and 10,000 more have come on
board in just the last 10 days
and thanks to your efforts we start the
job of building this movement from the
position of Greater electrical strength
than was apparent a year ago at the last
conference I ended my speech by urging
that we should all get out there
together and win and I want to say thank
you to each and every one of you for
answering that call because we had 75
net gains in the local elections in May
we got four new councils in Liberal
Democrat controlled including mine we
had our best results in 15 years
[Applause]
and shortly afterwards following a
massive effort from liberal Democrat
activists we had a 19 percent swing to
loosely salic at the low-income East
by-election his art was actually our
best results against labour for 14 years
there can be no doubt the Liberal
Democrats are growing and winning again
and this is just the beginning
the next step is to win and win big in
the local elections next year and Willie
Rennie and Jane Dodds and Caroline
pigeon are readiness for the big
devolved elections in 2020 as well but
meanwhile as we grow the tectonic plates
of British politics are shifting beneath
us the two big parties have changed from
broad churches into intolerant cults and
those who questioned and those who
questioned the faith are not welcome the
Labour leadership is dominated by people
who believe in doctrines that are very
far removed from the sensible social
democratic tradition that prevailed from
the days of Clement Attlee a Gordon
Brown and they in turn are the mirror
image of the Tory zealots who have more
in common with you kept than their
party's One Nation traditions
[Applause]
the so-called alts right the extremists
are well organized and they operate as
smoothly across frontiers as any
multinational company people of moderate
decent humane views are being
marginalized as this new illiberal
international take shape now much
depends on the courage of mainstream MPs
in the labor and conservative parties
they're losing control and if they can't
stop the rot they should leave but we
too must be bold there may be a
temptation to be what our colleagues in
Scotland might call the we freeze of
British politics sniffing suspiciously
at newcomers and outsiders who liked
doctrinal purity and we can't afford to
do that we have to become a bigger more
diverse movement and I would say that if
you don't call yourself a moderate
that's fine I'm a liberal and a social
democrat and I'm very far for a moderate
in my detestation of what is happening
at the extremes of British politics
[Applause]
but if others choose to identify
themselves as moderates who hates
extremism in their own parties we
shouldn't be quibbling about labels you
know let them in and if they're too shy
to come in
you know let's extend the hand of
friendship and cooperate with them
because there are millions of
dissatisfied people currently out there
waiting for a lead there are millions
who can see that the two main parties
have been hijacked by those who want to
turn their backs on the modern
interconnected world there are millions
who can see that there are massive
challenges housing crisis and aging
population the damaged environments a
fourth Industrial Revolution which our
paralyzed political system can't handle
now these millions of people are
potentially on our side and it's our job
to be on this
[Applause]
it will require bravery
single-mindedness and discipline for
those in the progressive center of
British politics to make common cause
but it can be done and I'm determined
that our party should be at the heart of
it leading the resistance to the forces
of liberalism leading the crusade to
give the people the final say on our
future in Europe and looking outwards to
a changing world with confidence and
determination that our values will
outlast and outclass the forces ranged
against them so I want
[Applause]
so I want to address the public directly
if you demand a better future this is
your chance our movement is your
movement it's an open movement with an
open leadership so join it shape it
build it because together we can and we
will win
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]